actually is in Texas Ashley how are you
I'm holding in there how about you do
better than I deserve what's up um well
I've hit my sick and tired of being sick
and tired moment my husband and I have a
ton of debt and we don't make enough to
get rid of it and I'm just I'm about to
lose my mind I'm just lost
hmm what's your household income um he
makes about thirty eight thousand five
hundred a year right now after taxes and
you don't work no I'm a stay-at-home
parent right now
how many babies just the one but he's
almost two years old okay all right and
what does your husband do for a living
he salesman for a driver for bluebells
okay and how long's you've been doing
that he's been there since the end of
February so it's still a new job is just
a route situation where's incomes going
to grow it may I've heard that it can go
up to about 50 grand a year again he
just started so we are not sure what
that's gonna where that's gonna go okay
I'm and you have one child and how much
debt do you guys have about 25 grand on
what most of it is my student loans my
car it we have a loan for that
how much do you own your car three
credit I believe last I checked it was
about 3900 okay and then credit cards as
well three of them yes okay and then a
hospital bill okay well there's two or
three things going on you do make enough
to get yourself out of this but barely
you don't make much money so that's one
of the things that's going on 38:5
take-home pay means he's making 46 48
thousand something like that a year and
it's a new job hopefully he can you know
get the route built up and
salesman for him then did Maury sells
some more money he'll make and certainly
good ice cream no question about that so
the good product in other words that
he's got that's a nice the nice part of
the equation but your high at the
average household income data from the
you know from the federal government the
average household income is fifty nine
thousand how old are you guys
uh he's 26 and I'm 25 okay so you're
young and getting started so it would
not be unusual that your household
income is less than the average right
that doesn't that just means you're
starting your careers and getting things
going before you had the baby what you
do we both actually worked in a radio
and television production we worked for
a Christian radio station in Colorado
okay alright so you didn't like much
money barely enough we were making it
yeah okay
so I would say let's do two or three
things number one the two of you sit
down tonight and get the every dollar
app downloaded onto your phone or into
your computer and sit down and do a
detailed budget for this month giving
this month's income every dollar of it
an assignment you will feel like you've
got a raise when you did that okay this
organization takes ten to fifteen
percent of your money away so just
getting organized and very intentional
about every dollar that's why we called
it that is a big deal that's a good part
of this and that'll get you started okay
but obviously the bigger the shovel you
have the faster you can fill the whole
land agreed and so I'm gonna say I'm
gonna send you a copy of Chris Christie
Wright's book business boutique to
inspire you to create some kind of an
income from home while you're home with
your baby and I think you can do that
and if you added ten thousand dollars
it'd be great and I'm gonna say he needs
an extra job I know he's working a lot
but oh well he needs an extra job and
you need to think about your long-term
he needs to think about you need to
think about your long-term career goals
where are we going to be
five or ten years making a hundred grand
and as and are we doing things that are
gonna take us there because that's where
you need to be aimed